now let's wrap you up on this what
message do you send out I think the
message is very clear with the numbers
and we ask a lot to accept it we're only
saying this so they know what time it is
the message our numbers are clear is a
message to them what message do you give
to the hindut yes not the Hindus
no but you've got to make sure that
distinction is made yes because nowadays
when I speak about one people yes the
papers will say I'm speaking about
another yes that was last time but since
Julio died this time and you know they
can't can't paste what I said you know
to change it yes my message to the
industry is that yes
[Music]
yes as I walk through the valley of the
shadow of death I turn around in my life
and realize there's nothing left because
I've been laughing and Blasting so long
that even my mama thinks that my mind is
gone because I never crossed a man that
didn't deserve it
like a punk you know that's unheard of
okay you better watch how you're talking
and where you're walking or you and your
boys will be lying in Chuck
the word
from back then
I made the messages clear brother
sisters
you know cause tensions but I think
things have calmed down the Muslims the
Hindu Community have come together you
know I've spoken to some of the some
Hindus actually themselves I went to the
house they invited me to the house you
know very lovely individuals we have
absolutely no problem with them they
know that but our attention is with the
media and those liars and we will expose
them and we are coming for them
intellectually until next time from
Speakers Corner